I believe that language must be taught together with culture.
For example, Japanese people always bow when they introduce themselves or say something like that
, such as body wang wedges.
Part 1 of the pressure
Every time I teach a rings spawn, do you say that it's related to that? I
'll definitely introduce the cultural background, for
example, when teaching
honorifics.  I will also introduce whether the relationship of offering is important.
Also, in the textbook, there is a tea note in each lesson,
so for example, in various topics such as the Japanese family system education system.  Since it is divided, I
also go to the Japanese class to introduce what kind of chart or culture you buy
.